This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every year in the spring, small towns throughout New England host their annual town meeting. Town meetings take place in high school gyms or town halls, and anyone can come. In fact, in Vermont, town meeting day is a public holiday. Everyone gets the day off work to make sure they have the chance to participate. It's a moment when everyone who lives there can come together and talk out the issues facing the town and decide how they want to spend their money. My parents used to drag me to town meeting. I mean, it's a remarkable institution.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。每年春天，新英格兰地区的许多小镇都会举办年度镇民大会。镇民大会通常在高中体育馆或镇政厅举行，任何人都可以参加。事实上，在佛蒙特州，镇民大会日是一个公共假期。每个人都可以放假一天，以确保他们有机会参与。这是一个让当地居民齐聚一堂、讨论镇上面临的问题并决定如何花钱的时刻。我的父母以前常常拉我去参加镇民大会。我的意思是，这是一个了不起的制度。
Eric Cahillman is a radio producer who lives in Vermont. She's been going to town meetings since she was a kid. And so I would go and everybody looks terrible because it's at the time of year is a radio producer who lives in Vermont, she's been going to town meetings since she was a kid. And so I would go and everybody looks terrible because it's at the time of year when everybody's been inside. Like they're smeared with salt and stuff and they look awful. But you know, people in a town become legislators for a day.
埃里克·卡尔曼是一位住在佛蒙特州的广播制作人。她从小就一直在参加镇民大会。所以我以前会去，每个人看起来都很糟糕，因为那是……她是一位住在佛蒙特州的广播制作人，从小就一直在参加镇民大会。所以我以前会去，每个人看起来都很糟糕，因为那是每个人都待在室内的季节。就像他们身上沾满了盐之类的东西，看起来糟透了。但你知道，镇上的人们会当一天立法者。
Erica is loathed to romanticize life in Vermont but she gets pretty romantic about town meeting. I am moved every time, every year I am moved by town meeting because every single person in that room has something to bring that is unique to them. And we may not need it that year, right? But it could be that we do, and they stand up, and they say they say their piece,
埃里卡很不愿把佛蒙特州的生活浪漫化，但她对镇民大会却有着相当浪漫的情怀。我每一次、每一年都被镇民大会所感动，因为房间里的每一个人都带来了一些属于他们自己的独特东西。也许我们当年不需要它，对吧？但可能我们确实需要，他们站起来，表达他们的看法，
and we say, oh my God, didn't know that, right? So everyone is deeply equal in that room. It's not always easy. There are disagreements. But Erica says people learn to disagree civilly, because in a small town, you have to rely on one another. A lot of these small towns depend on volunteers to function, And town meeting is the place where those roles get decided. Somebody's got to do the Cemetery Commission, right?
然后我们说：“天哪，我以前不知道。”对吧？所以在那个房间里，每个人都是绝对平等的。这并不总是那么容易。会有分歧。但埃里卡说，人们学会了文明地表达分歧，因为在一个小镇里，你必须相互依赖。许多这样的小镇依赖志愿者来运转，而镇民大会就是决定这些角色的地方。总得有人去管理公墓委员会吧？
And, you know, somebody's got to be on the zoning board or whatever. So everybody does a lot of boring, slow work to keep things going. And boring democracy and boring, slow democracy is actually the fastest, most effective democracy. That was a little historic, but I am a lover of town meeting. Erica is the host of a beautiful, unique jewel of a podcast. She's been making it for a long time, but I heard it for the first time pretty recently, and I was blown away. It reminded me of all the things I liked about radio
而且，你知道的，总得有人加入分区委员会之类的。所以每个人都在做大量枯燥、缓慢的工作来维持一切运转。而枯燥的民主，枯燥、缓慢的民主，其实是最快、最有效的民主。这有点历史感，但我是一个镇民大会的爱好者。埃里卡是一个美丽、独特的宝藏播客的主持人。她做这个节目已经很久了，但我不久前才第一次听到，并被深深地震撼了。它让我想起了我喜欢广播的所有原因
when I started in radio. It's sound rich, it's meaningful, it's transportive. It's ostensibly about life and Vermont, but it's kind of more about life in general. It's called Rumble Strip. So a Rumble Strip is one of those things on the side of the road that wakes you up when you're about to have a major car accident.
当我刚开始做广播的时候。它声音丰富，意味深长，引人入胜。表面上它是关于佛蒙特州的生活，但其实更像是关于一般的生活。它叫《Rumble Strip》。所以“Rumble Strip”（减速带/路面振动带）就是路边那种当你快要发生重大车祸时能把你唤醒的东西。
You know, it's essentially slow down and listen is the idea. So it's a very, you know, clean, clear message. It's a little bit trite if you actually spell it out like I just did. The stories that she tells are anything but trite. And the story we have for you today is all about town meeting.
你知道，它的核心理念基本上就是慢下来，听一听。所以这是一个非常干净、清晰的信息。如果你像我刚才那样把它直白地说出来，可能会有点老生常谈。但她讲述的故事绝不是老生常谈。我们今天为你带来的故事正是关于镇民大会的。
A Vermont tradition that anyone anywhere interested in how government functions can learn from. It was produced in 2021 for Rumble Strip. Here's Erica Heilmann. This is Rumble Strip, chapter one, Vernon Vermont town meeting. What to do about trash. Please state your name, Jeff Kosis.
这是佛蒙特州的一个传统，任何地方、任何对政府运作方式感兴趣的人都可以从中汲取经验。它是 2021 年为《Rumble Strip》制作的。这位是埃里卡·海尔曼。这里是《Rumble Strip》，第一章，佛蒙特州弗 Vernon 镇的镇民大会。如何处理垃圾。请报上你的姓名，杰夫·科西斯。
Some of us in this town already have a dumpster. so we don't have to walk out with those puny bags They don't hold anything. They're darn expensive and I don't feel like having to pay twice because in Frank when he go to Triple T truck and he tell you the recycling Just need to go away. We don't need about any to pay twice for my rubbish. So thank you Gerald recognize Mr. Gilligan. Patrick Gilligan, I believe the pay-as-you-throw program is a great benefit to the town of Vernon.
我们镇上的一些人已经有垃圾箱了，所以我们不必提着那些小袋子出门。它们什么也装不下，贵得要命，而且我不想付双倍的钱，因为坦白说，当他去找 Triple T 卡车公司时，他说回收利用这事简直该取消。我们不需要为我的垃圾付双倍的钱。谢谢你，杰拉德。请吉利根先生发言。帕特里克·吉利根，我认为按量付费项目对弗 Vernon 镇来说是一个巨大的福利。
Nor Mallor is my grandfather, I work at Triple T. He gave the town of Vernon a very good rate to do this. And I hope we all vote yes on this. Further discussion on the motion? The gentleman walking up to the microphone. I've heard a lot of people mention about how cheap pay as you throw is and I'm sure for our older families in town it may be but as a father of a family of three kids and a wife once you have a handful of
诺尔·马洛尔是我的祖父，我在 Triple T 工作。他给了弗 Vernon 镇一个非常优惠的价格来做这件事。我希望我们都对这个议案投赞成票。对该动议还有进一步的讨论吗？这位走向麦克风的男士。我听到很多人提到按量付费有多便宜，我确信对于镇上的老年家庭来说可能确实如此，但作为一个拥有三个孩子和一个妻子的家庭的父亲，一旦你拿了一把
diopries on those bags they break as you go down the driveway. This is a recording from town meeting in Vernon Vermont about trash removal and what the residents want to do about it, and it's not over. It goes on for another 20 minutes or so. Between the diapers for the children and the diapers for the elderly and all the little other pads in between,
尿布扔进那些袋子里，它们在沿着车道走的时候就会破掉。这是佛蒙特州弗 Vernon 镇关于垃圾清理以及居民们想如何处理它的镇民大会的录音，而且还没结束。它还要持续大约 20 分钟。除了孩子们的尿布、老人的尿布，以及中间所有其他的小垫子，
those things are recyclable and can be put in the cow bin. Town meeting is not glamorous. Sometimes it's boring. We sit on hard chairs. We talk about things like trash removal. But it is also the most civilized and surprising social gathering of the year. Every year. In most of New England, town citizens become legislators for one day a year.
这些东西都是可回收的，可以放进奶牛桶里。镇民大会并不光鲜亮丽。有时它很无聊。我们坐在硬椅子上。我们讨论垃圾清理之类的事情。但它也是一年中最文明、最令人惊叹的社交聚会。每年。在新英格兰的大多数地方，镇上的公民一年有一天会成为立法者。
They vote on issues that affect them directly, road conditions and property taxes and zoning laws, and sometimes they talk about more global concerns like immigration and climate change and what they can do about these things on a town level. It's not perfect. A lot of local power has eroded and is in the hands of the state and the federal government now. But every item that is on the agenda is voted on publicly and in person by town residents. It's one of the last examples of direct face-to-face democracy, and this century's long practice of towns doing the slow and hard work of disagreeing and arguing and compromising on how to govern themselves, this has a profound impact on a place and what it means to be from a place.
他们对直接影响他们的议题进行投票，比如道路状况、房产税和分区法，有时他们还会讨论更全球性的问题，比如移民、气候变化，以及他们在镇的层面上能为这些事情做些什么。它并不完美。许多地方权力已经被侵蚀，现在掌握在州政府和联邦政府手中。但议程上的每一项条款都由镇民公开且当面投票表决。这是直接面对面民主的最后几个例子之一，而且这种几个世纪以来小镇居民为如何治理自己而进行缓慢而艰难的分歧、争论和妥协的实践，对一个地方以及“作为一个地方的人”意味着什么产生了深远的影响。
The problem is we're not selling enough bags. In Vermont, town meeting is the first Tuesday in March. Everyone looks pretty bad after a long winter. Everyone's coat is covered in road salt. A lot of people seem to be sick of their spouses. Some people bring their knitting. They sit on bleachers in the school gym or in the town hall. And the select board, which are elected towns people,
问题是我们的袋子卖得不够多。在佛蒙特州，镇民大会在三月的第一个星期二举行。经过漫长的冬天，每个人看起来气色都不太好。每个人的外套上都沾满了道路盐。很多人似乎对自己的配偶感到厌烦。有些人带着织物去。他们坐在学校体育馆的看台或镇政厅里。精选委员会（Select Board），也就是选举出来的镇民，
they're sort of like the town's executive branch. They're usually sitting behind a table at the front of the room, and then there's the moderator who runs the meeting, or runs it as soon as the people of the town vote to select them, sometimes for the 50th year in a row. We're going to discussion on the article. Please state your name.
他们有点像是镇上的行政部门。他们通常坐在房间正前方的桌子后面，然后是主持会议的主持人，或者说，只要镇上的人投票选出他，他就开始主持会议，有时这已经是连续第 50 年了。我们将对该条款进行讨论。请报上你的姓名。
Most of us won't have town meeting this year because of COVID. Most towns will vote by ballot instead or Australian ballot as we call it here. So I figured this would be the year to make this show, to remember what we're missing. And even though this is a show about where I live, which is maybe not where you live, we're all living through a time of awful division, terrible public discourse. There aren't a lot of opportunities anymore to disagree civilly in public, and maybe there should be.
由于新冠疫情，我们大多数人今年都不会有镇民大会。大多数镇将改用选票投票，也就是我们这里所说的澳大利亚式不记名投票。所以我想今年制作这个节目，是为了记住我们所错失的东西。尽管这是一个关于我居住地方的节目，这个地方可能不是你居住的地方，但我们都正在经历一个可怕分裂、糟糕公共话语的时代。现在在公众面前文明地表达分歧的机会已经不多了，也许应该多一些。
I talked with town meeting moderators from all over Vermont about town meeting culture and what it's like to moderate these meetings. Here is some of what they said. My role is to ensure that the meeting remains the people's meeting. This is Kelly Green, defense attorney, and Randolph-town moderator. It's my job to ensure that the town's people get to transact the business that they want to transact. So this process recognizes that it is the people who run the town. We hold the power to get things done and do things. The people in the government are our servants. We direct the select board and the town to do our bidding.
我采访了来自佛蒙特州各地的镇民大会主持人，了解镇民大会的文化以及主持这些会议是什么感觉。以下是他们的一些言论。我的角色是确保会议依然是人民的会议。这是凯利·格林，辩护律师，也是伦道夫镇主持人。我的工作是确保镇民能够办理他们想要办理的事务。因此，这个过程承认，是人民在管理这个镇。我们拥有把事情办好、把事情做成的权力。政府里的人是我们的公仆。我们指示精选委员会和镇里执行我们的意愿。
It's unbelievable if you think about it. I mean, I don't know that people really understand that they have this authority and power. I'm not sure everybody understands it. You are literally legislating from the floor. It's beautiful. Most for munchers understand that government is a we, not a they. This is Susan Clark, author and middle-sex town moderator.
如果你仔细想想，这简直难以置信。我的意思是，我不知道人们是否真正理解他们拥有这种权威和权力。我不确定每个人都理解这一点。你实际上就是在议会大厅里立法。这太美妙了。大多数佛蒙特州人明白政府是一个“我们”，而不是一个“他们”。这是苏珊·克拉克，作家兼米德尔塞克斯镇主持人。
It's a thing that we do together, or if we don't, it's by choice, because we're definitely invited. And somebody's always going to call you and ask you to be on some darn committee. I know. If you're not on one, it's because you've avoided them. And that's what it means. I think it's gonna make us less likely to want to storm the Capitol if we understand that we all are part of what makes the democracy tick. Good morning. It being 9 a.m. on the 3rd of March 2020 in the town of Richmond, Vermont, I call this 225th annual town meeting to order.
这是我们一起做的事情，如果我们不这么做，那也是我们自己的选择，因为我们绝对受到了邀请。而且总有人会打电话给你，请你加入某个该死的委员会。我知道。如果你不在其中一个委员会里，那是因为你一直在躲避它们。这就是它的意义所在。我认为，如果我们理解我们所有人都是让民主运转的一部分，这会让我们不那么想去冲击国会山。早上好。今天是 2020 年 3 月 3 日上午 9 点，在佛蒙特州里士满镇，我宣布第 225 届年度镇民大会开幕。
This is Stephen McGill, ski patrol, beer brewer, and more town town manager, and we went to high school together. Is there a story related to how you became moderator? Did you just, it seems like all the people have talked to you, they kind of back into it. Oh no, no, I fronted into it. I'm probably one of the only people in the state
这是斯蒂芬·麦吉尔，滑雪巡逻员、啤酒酿造商，还有更多身份的镇经理，我们曾经是高中同学。关于你如何成为主持人，有什么相关的故事吗？你是不是……感觉所有和你谈过的人都是阴差阳错走上这条路的。哦，不，不，我是主动冲上去的。我可能是州里唯一一个
that's ever actually run against an incumbent moderator and one. What was your rationale for running against this incumbent? The people in town were ready for somebody different. It was a challenging decision because the guy who was the incumbent is a really good guy. And he's still active in town politics. He's an old dairy farmer, and people were just ready for somebody different, and they asked if I would be willing to run, and they asked the right person, because I think it's fun. But about three years after that, we got, it was a particularly challenging meeting, lots of interesting questions, and that's what makes it fun, lots of good back and forth and amendments.
真正竞选并击败现任主持人的人。你当时竞选击败这位现任主持人的理由是什么？镇上的人们已经准备好迎接一个不同的人了。这是一个充满挑战的决定，因为身为现任者的那个人是一个非常好的人。而且他至今仍活跃在镇上的政治活动中。他是一个老奶农，而人们只是准备好迎接一个不同的人了，他们问我是否愿意参选，他们找对了人，因为我觉得这很有趣。但在那之后大约三年，我们遇到了一次，那是一次特别具有挑战性的会议，有很多有趣的问题，这正是它的乐趣所在，有很多很好的来回辩论和修正案。
At the end of the meeting when he gets to other business, the guy who had formerly been the moderator raised his hand, and I called on him, and he, from the back of the room, said, I just want to thank the moderator for doing a really good job today. He goes, I know that this is a really hard thing to do. And he's done a splendid job, and I just really want to thank him. It was a blessing from the previous moderator for what I have to do now. So it was a great moment. I often actually don't know what anyone's talking about.
在会议结束时，当进行到“其他事项”环节时，前任主持人举起了手，我点了他的名，他从房间后排说：“我只想感谢主持人的工作，他今天做得真的很好。”他说：“我知道这是一件非常难做的事情。他做得非常出色，我真的只想感谢他。”这是前任主持人对我现在所做工作的祝福。所以那是一个伟大的时刻。我其实经常不知道大家在谈论什么。
I really have no idea what the capital budget fund is about. I do not understand any of it. People could be speaking Greek. But what I do know how to do, what I am good at, is empathizing with the person speaking. And because I don't really know all the ins and outs of all the stuff that goes on in town, I have to listen carefully to them and understand what they're saying. And, you know, if, if necessary, help that person get their thought
我真的不知道资本预算基金是关于什么的。我一点也听不懂。大家说的可能都是希腊语。但我知道该怎么做，我擅长的是对发言的人感同身受。因为我并不真正了解镇上发生的各种事情的内幕，我必须仔细倾听他们的话，理解他们在表达什么。而且，你知道的，如果有必要，帮助那个人表达出他们的想法
out or use the rules to take some action, whatever. Some people are really excellent speakers. Some people are not. Some people are terrified. Some people talk too much. But it seems like, as a body, the people have room for it all. This is Paul Doughton, Dairy Farmer and Barnard Town moderator. In my management, so called of the town meeting, I really don't have total control. I just try to keep it within the railings, I guess, of what needs to be. And one of the things I point out is that everybody addresses their comments to the moderator, and then the moderator will ask the question, so there aren't two people that are arguing across the room, which can be and has been sometimes a problem because the motions get in the way.
或者利用规则采取某种行动，诸如此类。有些人是非常出色的演讲者。有些人则不然。有些人吓得要死。有些人话太多。但作为一个整体，人们似乎对这一切都有包容度。这是保罗·多顿，奶农兼巴纳德镇主持人。在我对镇民大会的所谓“管理”中，我其实并没有完全的控制权。我只是尽量把它控制在需要的范围内，我想。我指出的事情之一就是，所有人都把他们的意见向主持人陈述，然后主持人会提出问题，这样就不会有两个人隔着房间争吵，这可能曾经是、现在也偶尔是一个问题，因为情绪会妨碍事情。
And I try to make sure emotions are set aside. Usually with success, but not always. It frequently will happen that somebody will talk at a turn just a General reminder, you know, hey Joe has the floor right now that works great Yeah, you're snickering. No, I was like it's like so easy. It's so easy But you just have to be there and be ready and not let it get out of hand in a minute It starts to happen. You got to say No, you don't have the floor. I don't care if you're agreeing or disagreeing or what your, what your, doesn't matter what
我尽量确保把情绪放在一边。通常会成功，但并非总是如此。经常会发生的情况是，有人不按顺序发言。只是一个温馨的提醒，你知道的，“嘿，乔现在拥有发言权”这招很管用。是的，你在偷笑。不，我当时觉得这太简单了。太简单了。但你必须身在其中，时刻准备着，不能让场面失控。一旦这种情况开始发生，你就得说：“不，你没有发言权。我不管你是同意还是反对，或者你的……不管你在说什么。
you're saying. You do not have the floor. That's the important thing, okay? I've only once had to really use my stern voice. And I'm not really a stern person, so it kind of, I have to make it up. But we had somebody that tried, well, he, somebody who had the floor, and well, he had the floor, somebody else raised their hand, and he turned and said, put your hand down, I'm talking. And that's the only time I ever used my gavel. And I said, you are not in charge of the meeting, this is my meeting, and anybody who wants to put their hand up is allowed to put their hand up. Is that your stern voice?
你没有发言权。这是最重要的事情，好吗？”我只有一次真正不得不使用我严厉的语气。我其实不是一个严厉的人，所以这有点像……我必须装出来。但我们当时有一个人试图……好吧，他，某个拥有发言权的人，就在他拥有发言权的时候，另一个人举起了手，他转过身说：“把你的手放下，我在说话。”那是唯一一次我使用我的木槌。我说：“你不是这个会议的负责人，这是我的会议，任何想举手的人都有权举手。”那是你严厉的语气吗？
That, no. That is not my stern voice. You can't do your stern voice, just so you can hear it. What are we... I'm gonna wait just a second. What's going on? It's no mobile. It's no mobile, What's going on? It's no more bills. Snow more bills, come on by. What's going on? Snow more bills, come on by. This is what you get when you do an interview in the garage.
那个，不。那不是我严厉的语气。你不能来一段你的严厉语调，好让我听听吗？我们正在……我等一会儿。怎么回事？没账单了。没账单了，快来看看。怎么回事？没账单了，快来看看。这就是你在车库里做采访时会遇到的情况。
This is Bobby Star, X-Truck Driver, Vermont Legislator and Troy Town moderator for 50 years. I think it's the moderator's job to make people feel comfortable enough so they don't give a hoot if they say it if the words come out wrong We'll get it figured out just say him and You know you have all types of people that show up you go from the poorest person in town or the least educated professors and doctors. And a lot of times that person with the least amount of education makes more sense than the professor made. So you know, it doesn't matter who you are or what you are.
这是鲍比·斯塔尔，前卡车司机、佛蒙特州立法者，担任特洛伊镇主持人已有 50 年。我认为主持人的职责就是让人们感到足够舒适，这样即使他们说错了词，他们也毫不在乎。我们会把它弄清楚的，说出来就行。你知道的，你会看到各种各样的人出现，从镇上最穷的人或受教育程度最低的人，到教授和医生。很多时候，那个受教育程度最低的人说的话比教授说的更有道理。所以你知道的，你是谁或你是什么并不重要。
The important thing is to participate. This is John McLeary, political policy advisor, and Kirbytown moderator for 55 years. Everybody's got something to contribute that they know that most people don't. And it may not be something that comes up in which case they take it with them and leave the room at the end of the meeting.
重要的是参与。这是约翰·麦克利里，政治政策顾问，担任柯比镇主持人已有 55 年。每个人都有一些他们知道的、而大多数人不知道的东西可以贡献出来。可能有些事情最终并没有被提及，这种情况下，他们在会议结束时会带着它离开房间。
But sometimes people got something to say, that it says, well, I happen to work in home care for 27 years and I can tell you what really happens with the state agencies and the hospital and so on. And that's one of the great things about town meeting is that it reassures the people who come here that where they have something to say and they're not just blowing hot air, people are grateful to have that input. When you stand up to make your speech here, you're not petitioning a higher power to do your what you're not going to hearing.
但有时人们有话要说，他们会说：“嗯，我碰巧在家庭护理行业工作了 27 年，我可以告诉你州机构和医院等地真正发生了什么。”镇民大会的伟大之处之一就在于，它让来到这里的人们确信，他们有话要说，他们不是在空谈，人们对有这样的建言表示感激。当你站在这里发表演讲时，你不是在向一个更高的权力请愿，你也不是在参加听证会。
Many of the hearings the legislature has are, I hate to say shams, but they're pro forma exercises which have very little impact on the actual legislators. But here you have a right to be here, you have a right to be heard, your voice is good as anybody's voice, and although you may not be on the winning side every time, you know that you're exercising, you're right to democratic self-government and have and can make a difference. How did the Bolton respond last night? My understanding is they offered $275. The report that we got from the Bolton Townsler QR correct.
立法机构举行的许多听证会，我不想说是虚假的，但它们是流于形式的走过场，对实际的立法者几乎没有什么影响。但在这里，你有权来到这里，你有权被听到，你的声音和任何人的声音一样好，虽然你可能不会每一次都站在获胜的一方，但你知道你在行使你民主自治的权利，并且能够产生影响。博尔顿（Bolton）昨晚是怎么回应的？我的理解是他们提供了 275 美元。我们从博尔顿镇办事处得到的报告是准确的。
So I think it's a little disproportionate here. This number is just, I don't understand how it can be justified. Volunteerism, I've done my share, I'm still doing it. I don't see where we need to have it turned over to the taxpayers. I think raise your money, you're getting enough now. That's my opinion. I think that's just too much, too much. Thank you.
所以我认为这在这里有点不成比例。这个数字简直了，我不知道这怎么能合情合理。志愿服务，我已经尽了我的职责，我仍在继续。我看不出我们为什么需要把它交给纳税人处理。我认为你们自己筹钱吧，你们现在得到的已经够多了。这就是我的看法。我认为这实在是太多了，太多了。谢谢。
If you have a real disagreement with somebody, you don't have to be disagreeable. You can agree to disagree and move on. Because in a day or two, you may come upon that person at the store, at the post office, or someplace, and you have to come to a time of reckoning that we cannot continue to be is vile to one another as the internet and that whatever the other media is that people can just spout off and not have to worry about the repercussions. This is Gus Sealig, Executive Director of Vermont Housing and Calis Town moderator. The other thing that is special about it is it is a way to get to know people that are
如果你和某人有真正的分歧，你不必表现得讨人嫌。你可以求同存异，然后继续前进。因为在一两天内，你可能会在商店、邮局或其他什么地方遇到那个人，你必须迎来一个清算的时刻：我们不能继续像互联网和其他媒体那样对彼此充满恶意，在那里人们可以随心所欲地大放厥词，而不必担心后果。这是格斯·塞利格，佛蒙特州住房执行董事兼卡利斯镇主持人。关于它的另一件特别的事情是，它是一种了解那些超出你正常社交圈的人的方式。
outside of your normal social circle. everything that is special about it is it is a way to get to know people that are outside of your normal social circle. See people and learn from people and hear people that may not be part of the group that they would usually hang around with. And in an age where everybody's going to their own television station, that just reinforces what you already think, the opportunity to go someplace and have people with whom you disagree, speak to you, is I think something that's still worth investing in.
关于它的每一件特别的事情是，它是一种了解那些超出你正常社交圈的人的方式。看到人们、向人们学习，并听到那些可能不属于他们通常交往圈子的人的声音。在这个每个人都只看自己倾向的电视台、只会强化自己既有看法的时代，去一个地方，听取那些与你意见相左的人向你说话的机会，我认为仍然是一件值得投资的事情。
I think there was an article warned on whether Vermont should pay livable wages. And one person got up and said, if I have to pay people, I can't remember what the number was this much an hour, then I'm going to have to raise my prices and you folks won't be able to afford my services. And the next person got up and said,
我想当时有一个关于佛蒙特州是否应该支付体面工资的议案讨论。一个人站起来说，如果我必须付给人们——我不记得具体数字是多少了——这么多钱一小时，那么我就不得不提高我的价格，你们这些人就承担不起我的服务了。然后另一个人站起来说，
and if the people you pay don't make enough and they're on food stamps, and they need heating assistance, I've got to pay for that. So within three minutes, we had the whole debate about livable wages and we didn't resolve that that day, but again, it was a great opportunity for people to have to listen to each other and hear from each other about what was important to them. There is a civilizing aspect of town meeting. You're both comfortable, largely comfortable.
如果你付钱的人赚得不够，他们就要靠食品券生活，他们需要取暖援助，那我就得为之买单。因此，在三分钟内，我们就进行了关于体面工资的完整辩论，我们那天并没有解决这个问题，但再说一次，这对于人们来说是一个绝佳的机会，他们不得不倾听彼此，并从对方那里听到什么对他们是重要的。镇民大会有一种使人文明化的作用。你们都感到舒适，在很大程度上感到舒适。
It's the same people, it's your town, you're largely comfortable, you're knitting, you know, like you've had a donut, you're comfortable. You know these people, you know these people well. So you're comfortable, but it's also public and there is some formality to it People feel safe to say what's on their mind in their own way of saying things Sometimes it gets heated Sometimes it's sad, sometimes it's funny
都是同样的人，这是你们的小镇，你们在很大程度上感到舒适，你在织毛衣，你知道的，就像你吃过一个甜甜圈一样，你很舒适。你认识这些人，你非常了解这些人。所以你感到舒适，但它也是公开的，并且有一定的形式感。人们觉得可以安全地以自己的方式说出心里话。有时气氛会变得激烈。有时它是悲伤的，有时它是滑稽的。
There is this beautiful balance that happens, right? It's not sanitary. It's not boring. It's not sanitary. It's not, you know, it's real. It's authentic. But it's always civil. I am never more nervous speaking publicly than I am at town meeting. Why? Why is... Why are the stakes so high when I stand up at town meeting to say something? That's so true. You can't go home afterwards. You already are home. And so here you are being yourself. It's high, high, high stakes. On the other hand, it should be the lowest of stakes because these are your neighbors who've got your back. It's not that we necessarily are going to love each other at town meeting. But we do want to succeed. The worst thing that can happen at a meeting, and it's very rare, is that we come out without
这里发生着一种美丽的平衡，对吧？它不是被消毒过的。它不是无聊的。它不是被消毒过的。它不是，你知道的，它是真实的。它是原汁原味的。但它永远是文明的。我在公众面前发言时，从未像在镇民大会上那样感到如此紧张。为什么？为什么……当我站在镇民大会上说点什么时，利害关系会这么高？确实如此。你事后不能回家。你本来就已经在家了。所以在这里，你就是在做你自己。利害关系太高、太高、太高了。另一方面，它本该是利害关系最低的事情，因为这些人都是你的邻居，他们会支持你。这并不是说我们在镇民大会上就一定会相亲相爱。但我们的确渴望成功。在会议上可能发生的糟糕的事情——而且这非常罕见——就是我们没有得出
an answer. That's a super easy thing to happen without box voting. Let's just vote no. Uhhh, you know, we'll tell them, well then you don't have a budget. The thing about meetings is that you just have to stay until you find it, until you work to get it. We're not, we're not gonna, you know, completely agree with each other, but to be able to understand what are the points that we can move forward together on? What's the, in the then diagram of ideas,
一个答案就散会了。如果不进行箱内投票，这可以说是极其容易发生的事。让我们直接投反对票吧。呃，你知道的，我们会告诉他们，那你们就没有预算了。会议的精髓就在于，你必须留下来直到找到答案，直到你努力去争取它。我们不会，我们不会，你知道的，完全彼此同意，但能够理解我们可以朝着哪些共同点共同前进？在想法的维恩图里，
where's the overlap? If you lose a town meeting, what kind of conversations do not happen? Well, what happens is you don't have any discussion. You do everything by Australian ballot. How do you alter? How do you discuss like your budget, or the road budget,
重叠的部分在哪里？如果你取消了镇民大会，就不会发生什么样的对话？好吧，发生的情况是你们没有任何讨论。你们用澳大利亚式不记名投票来做所有事情。你如何修改？你如何讨论比如你的预算、道路预算、
or the fire budget, or this school budget. It's all you're gonna do is mark an ax on a paper at your leisure and put it in a little box, but you're never gonna be able to discuss the real issue while it too much, is it too little. You miss that whole debate. It serves no purpose. Australian balloting ought to be outlawed as far as I'm concerned.
消防预算，或是学校预算。你所要做的就是在你闲暇时在纸上打个叉，然后把它投进一个小盒子里，但你永远无法讨论真正的问题：它是太多了，还是太少了。你错过了整个辩论。这毫无意义。依我看，澳大利亚式不记名投票应该被取缔。
People will say sometimes that it's inefficient. It takes long sometimes to talk through the answers. They'll say, wouldn't it just be so much more efficient to just have a ballot and vote yes or no? And not only efficient, by the way, but more people will vote if you ask them to vote, then if you ask them to come to a meeting. So, isn't that better? That's more democracy. But every year it happens that people rely on the meeting to inform their vote. I remember the year when we talked about whether we were going to switch to a sterling ballot or not, and I
人们有时会说这效率低下。把答案讨论清楚有时需要很长时间。他们会说：“举行投票并投赞成或反对票难道不是效率高得多吗？”不仅有效率，顺便说一句，如果你要求人们投票，比要求他们来参加会议会有更多的人投票。那么，这样不是更好吗？这才是更多的民主。但每年都会发生这种情况，人们依靠会议来为他们的投票提供信息。我记得当年我们讨论是否要转为斯特林不记名投票时，我
went into that meeting and asked one of my neighbors, you know, how are you going to vote? And he said, yeah, I'm not sure. I'm going to listen to the debate and decide, just laughed and I said, I think there's your answer, my friend. You know, right now, the old Max house, right there, like Douglass Old Garage here. Okay, every time we flood that, it builds the basement of the water now. I talked to Pat Mail, where Pat Mail grew up.
走进那个会议，问我的一个邻居，“你知道，你打算怎么投票？”他说：“嗯，我不确定。我打算听听辩论再决定。”然后他笑了，我说：“我想这就是你的答案，我的朋友。”你知道的，现在，老马克斯的房子，就在那儿，就像道格拉斯的老车库这里。好吧，每次我们把那里淹了，它现在就会把地下水涌进地下室。我跟帕特·梅尔谈过，帕特·梅尔长大的地方。
He said, that was not them. He said, our house was always full of water. I just, you know, we turn around and build that road up now. You think about it. Something else has come pay for it. We said our house was all water. We turned around to build that road up now. You'd think about it. Something else has gone painful. That's why we're looking.
他说，那不是他们。他说，我们的房子总是积满水。我只是，你知道的，我们现在掉头把那条路修高。你想想看。别的东西来为此买单。我们说我们的房子全是水。我们现在掉头把那条路修高。你会考虑的。别的东西已经付过代价了。这就是我们正在寻找的。
I remember a town meeting where our town, a child had gone missing in our town. And the FBI came to town to investigate immediately. And had gone to the library. They had a tip and wanted to seize and search the library's public computers. In the librarians told the FBI that they needed to get a warrant. The town was grief-stricken and was enraged that the library
我记得有一次镇民大会，我们镇上有一个孩子失踪了。联邦调查局（FBI）立即来到镇上进行调查。他们去了图书馆。他们得到了一条线索，想要扣押并搜查图书馆的公共电脑。图书馆员告诉联邦调查局，他们需要获得搜查令。全镇陷入悲痛，并对图书馆
was in danger of the public. The town was grief-stricken and was enraged that the library would, at a time like that, demand that the FBI get a warrant? Like everyone in town was like, are you kidding me? A child is missing? And what? This town meeting afterwards afterwards the library budget of course is on is up for discussion as it is every year and the people were still really angry with the library but a patron and I think trustee of the library again a volunteer, someone living in
在那种时刻竟然要求联邦调查局获得搜查令感到愤怒？就像镇上的每个人都觉得：“你在开玩笑吗？一个孩子失踪了？然后呢？”而在这之后的镇民大会上，图书馆的预算一如既往地像每年一样提出来讨论，人们对图书馆仍然非常愤怒，但图书馆的一位读者——我想也是图书馆的理事，同样是一位志愿者、镇上的居民、一位老妇人——站起来，向会场上的人们发表了我有生以来见过的对第四修正案和公民自由最热烈、最激情的辩护。而且，你知道的，我是一名刑事辩护律师。我整天都在努力发表关于第四修正案的演讲。而这位同样因为这起罪行而
town, elderly woman stood up and gave the most passionate defense of the fourth amendment and civil liberties to the people on the floor that I have ever witnessed. And, you know, I'm a criminal defense attorney. I spend all day trying to make speeches about the Fourth Amendment. And this woman who also had been, you know, moved with grief about this crime
悲痛欲绝的女性，也能发表这样一场聪明、充满同情心的演讲，以至于人们在事后报以热烈的掌声。她确实说服了人们去理解，为什么在那个时刻，我们的公民自由确实至关重要。每个人都很悲伤，但都被她的演讲打动了。图书馆预算通过了吗？图书馆预算通过了。我总是感到惊讶，
could also give this smart, compassionate speech where people applauded afterwards. She really persuaded people to understand why at that moment was when our civil liberties did matter. Everyone was sad, but was moved by her speech. Did the library budget pass? The library budget passed. I'm always surprised.
并对那些闪耀光芒的邻居肃然起敬、惊叹不已。第二个通知是，我加入了一个名为“希望与行动”的人员委员会，该委员会一直在镇政厅举办晚宴和娱乐活动。如果你错过了过去这一年的卡拉OK，你就错过了一场精彩的表演。我认为人们不理解镇民大会涉及多少本地的志愿服务。
And in awe, and bold over by a neighbor who shines. The second announcement is, I'm on a committee of people called Hope and Action that has been putting on dinners and entertainment here at the Town Hall. If you missed karaoke this past year, you missed a great performance. I don't think people understand how much local volunteerism is involved in town meeting.
还有镇上的整个政府运作过程，我的意思是，比如审计员，镇民就是审计员，而不是做账的官方审计事务所。审计员是负责汇编镇报告的人。这需要付出很大的努力。他们没有审计员的资格。他们的职业可能是——我不确定是什么——但我知道其中两人目前已经退休了，
And the whole governmental process of towns, I mean, take, for instance, the auditors, townspeople are auditors, not the official audit firm that does the books. The auditors are the ones that put together the town report. And that takes a lot of effort. They aren't qualified as auditors. Their profession might be, I'm not sure what it is, but two of them, I know, are retired
他们之所以在委员会里，是因为前几天我收到其中一人发来的电子邮件，问他是否可以把镇报告放在我们卖玉米的夏日棚子里。但人们就是会涌现出来，做任何需要做的事情。其中一些看起来并不那么重要、也不是很高层面的委员会，有时结果证明远不止于此。我的意思是，公墓委员会成员，其中有两个人一直在为这个公墓工作，我外祖父就埋在农场后面的那个公墓里，他们扶正墓碑并处理所有这类事情。这就是当地人如何参与其中的一个例子。
right now that are on there because I had an email from one of them the other night asking if he could leave town reports here in our summer shed where we sell corn. But people just surface and do whatever they need to do. Some of these committees that don't seem, you don't think are real important or high level, sometimes turn out to be much more than that. I mean, the Seminary Commissioners, two of them have been working on this cemetery for my maternal grandfather's buried just behind the farm here, straightening up stones and bringing all that type stuff. That's one example of how local people get involved.
一次又一次，我们被要求参与多年的、几十年的、甚至几个世纪的小决定。改变的是文化。我们实际上拥有镇民大会的文化，即使你从未参加过镇民大会，也许你住在城市里。我们在佛蒙特州有文明的期望，我们有期望。有包容性的期望，在决定下达之前，我们期望被征求意见。
Again and again, we're asked to be involved in small decisions over years, over decades, over literally centuries. What changes is the culture. We actually have a town meeting culture, and even if you have never attended a town meeting, maybe you live in a city. We have expectations in Vermont. Of civility, we have expectations. Of inclusion, we expect to be asked about things before decisions come down.
我们在佛蒙特州拥有其他地方可能没有的民主期望。我认为许多其他地方并没有这种期望。因为这是我们几个世纪以来创造的镇民大会文化。当我们谈论镇民大会日时，我们不仅在谈论一天。镇民大会日，我们不仅在谈论一天。镇民大会日是一种文化。所以在佛蒙特州的每个镇，人们都必须参与镇务。实际上，在每个镇、几乎每个镇，都是由人民来管理这个镇。为了完成镇上的工作，无论是管理镇公墓的草坪修剪、运营娱乐项目还是弄清楚预算，都需要数百、数千
We have democratic expectations in Vermont that other places might not have. That I think many other places do not have. Because of a town meeting culture that we have created over centuries. When we talk about town meeting day, we're not just talking about one day. Town meeting day, we're not just talking about one day. Town meeting day is a culture. So in every town in Vermont, the people have to be involved in town affairs. Literally, the people run the town in every town, almost every town. To get the work of town done, whether it's managing the lawn mowing at the town cemetery or running recreational programs or figuring out the budget, it takes hundreds, thousands
小时的志愿者时间。所以每个人都必须出一份力。我们并不完全在所有事情上、甚至在任何事情上都达成一致，但作为一个每个人都必须参与、否则什么也做不成的镇，我们彼此高度依赖。所以这是一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，我不知道是佛蒙特州人本来就是这样、然后我们发明了镇民大会，还是镇民大会让我们变成了这样。但我们生活在我们的社区里，我们高度依赖彼此。如果有问题，如果有危机，大家已经有了彼此的电话号码。
of volunteer hours. So everybody has to pitch in. And we don't all agree at all on everything or even anything, but as a result of having a town where everyone has to participate or nothing gets done, we're very interdependent. So it's a chicken and egg question like, I don't know if like Vermonters were like this and then we invented town meeting or if town meeting made us like this. But we live in our community, we are very interdependent. If there's a problem, if there's a crisis, people have each other's phone numbers already.
对于我们这些有电子邮箱的人来说，大家也有彼此的电子邮件地址。你知道遇到问题或提供帮助时该打电话给谁。有时，当人们听到“社会资本”这个词时，他们会觉得它的意思是像“哦，我们有很多聚餐，你知道的”，并且我们认为，只要我们一起进行社交，我们就会拥有丰富的社会资本。但建立社会资本的很大一部分，意味着它是赢得的。
People have each other's email addresses for those of us with email. And you know who to call with your problem or your offer of assistance. Sometimes when people hear the term social capital, they think it means social like, oh, we have lots of potlucks, you know, and we think that if we just socialize together, then we'll have rich social capital. But a big part of building that, it means earned.
它是赢得的。它是我们存入社会资本银行账户的东西，你不能仅仅通过野餐来做到这一点。你是通过彼此产生分歧、然后努力寻找共同前进道路的艰难工作来做到这一点的。正是对自治这项艰难工作的投资，让我们成为一个社会，让我们成为一个社区，这样当艰难时期来临——你知道的，我们镇上正在发生非常困难的事情，我们要如何支付洪水损失？——我们多年来一直在投资这种社会资本，以便当艰难时期来临、需要进行自治的艰难工作时，我们已经准备好了，我们需要坐下来开漫长的会议，倾听不同的观点，
It's earned. It's something that we put into our social capital bank account and you don't just do it through picnics. You do it through the hard work of disagreeing with each other and then working to find the way to move forward together anyway. It's what makes us a society, what's what makes us a community is investing in the hard work of self-governance so that when the hard times come, you know, something really difficult is going on in our town, how are we going to pay for flood damage? We have invested over the years in that social capital so that we are ready when the hard times come for the hard work of self-governance, where we have to sit through a long meeting and hear different points of view
然后共同找到前进的道路。国会山感觉跟我没有任何关系。我知道这不是真的。我知道这不是真的。我是一名律师，所以我知道华盛顿发生的事情在这里会有影响。但出于某种原因，那些发生的事与我的生活之间存在一种脱节。我的小镇才真正是我的现实。日复一日。我想我是一个相当独特的人，因为我和我妻子每三个月才用一个绿色垃圾袋。其中很大一部分原因是我们不把垃圾扔进垃圾桶。
and then find the way forward together. capitol feels like it has nothing to do with me whatsoever. I know that's not true. I know that that's not true. I'm a lawyer, so I know that what happens in Washington has effects here. But for some reason, there is a disconnect between what happens on those in my life. My town is really my reality. Day in and day out. I guess I'm kind of a unique individual because my wife and I, we use one green bag every three months. And a big part of that is we don't throw garbage in our trash can.
我们把它放进袋子里，放在冰箱里，然后一周一次我把它拿到奶牛桶那里去。我可以在一个袋子里装进 3 个 13 加仑的垃圾袋。这就是镇民大会。如果你想看一些镇民大会的照片，你可以访问我的网站 rumblestripvermont.com。此外，米德尔塞克斯镇主持人苏珊·克拉克与人合著了一本书，名为《缓慢的民主：重新发现社区并将决策权带回本土》。它讲述了这里谈到的所有事情以及更多内容，真的非常棒。我也会在网站上放一个指向它的链接。如果你想对
We put that in a bag, we keep it in the freezer, and then once a week I take it down to the cow. I can put 3, 13 gallon trash bags in one bag. That was town meeting. If you want to see some pictures of town meeting, you can visit my website rumblestripvermont.com. Also, Middlesex Town moderator Susan Clark co-authored a book called Slow Democracy Rediscovering Community and Bringing Decision-Making Back Home. It's about all of the things that they talked about here and a lot more and it's really good. I'll put a link to it on the website also. If you want to make a comment on the
节目发表评论，我很乐意倾听。只需转到节目页面，在节目页面的底部你会看到一个评论框。如果你想为节目捐款，那也太棒了。这能给我的汽车加满油。同时也感谢所有已经和正在捐款的人。我要感谢托宾、凯利和阿梅利亚对这个节目的帮助。感谢卡利斯的音乐家也是家具制作人的布赖恩·克拉克为节目创作的音乐。我在我的网站上提供了他的音乐和家具的链接。感谢安吉拉翻找她的录音带抽屉，感谢布拉特尔伯勒社区电视台和曼斯菲尔德山社区电视台
show, I would love to hear it. Just go to the show page and at the bottom of the show page you'll see a comment box. If you want to make a donation to the show, that would also be great. It puts gas in my car. And thank you also to all of the people who already make and have made donations. I want to thank Tobin, Kelly, and Amelia for their help on this show. And thanks to Callis' musician and also furniture maker Brian Clark for his music. I have links to his music and his furniture on my website. Thank you to Angela for digging into her taped bin and thanks to Brattleboro Community Television and Mount Mansfield Community Television
提供的镇民大会录音。还要感谢所有勇敢地在这些会议上站起来发言的人。这有一种奇怪的威慑感。Rumble Strip 是 Hobben's Spoke 的骄傲成员，这是一个由来自全国各地的优秀、独立且聪明绝顶的播客组成的集体。你可以在 hubspokeaudio.org 找到他们。这里是《Rumble Strip》，我是埃里卡·海尔曼。非常感谢收听。在接下来的节目之后，我和埃里卡将聊聊她是如何制作……
for their recordings of town meeting. And also all the brave people who get up and talk in those meetings. It's weirdly intimidating. Rumble Strip is a proud member of Hobben's Spoke, a collective of excellent and independent and wicked smart podcasters from all over the country. You can find them at hubspokeaudio.org. This is Rumble Strip, America Hyalman. Thanks a lot for listening. Coming up after the break, Erica and I talk about how she makes
愒者们对镇上会议的录音。还有所有那些在会记上站起来发言的勇敢人们。这真是一种奇怪的威肁。Rumble Strip 是 Hobben's Spoke 的自豪成员，这是一个来自全嚽各地、优秀、独立且肀痛聪慧的播客集体。您可以在 hubspokeaudio.org 找到他们。这是 Rumble Strip，美国海尔曼。非常感谢您的收听。休息过后，我和艾丽卡将聈聊他是如何制作
her show. And she tricks me into talking a little bit about how we make ours. So tell me a little bit about the origin story of Rumble Strip. Well, it started out as Rumble Strip for a month, but it's funny when you make a show anywhere, but New York and LA and Seattle and Toronto, if you make a show in Topeka, people kind of expect that your show is about Topeka.
她的节目。她还套话让我讲了一些我们是怎么做自己的节目的。所以跟我讲讲“Rumble Strip”这个节目的起源故事吧。嗯，它一开始叫“Rumble Strip for a month”，但很有意思，无论你在哪里做节目——除了纽约、洛杉矶、西雅图和多伦多以外——如果你在托皮卡做节目，人们就会理所当然地以为你的节目是关于托皮卡的。
It's weird. It's like if you don't live in a major city, then if you live in a small place, it must be that you're making a show about that place. I don't get it. But that's kind of why I dropped the Vermont. It might mean my show features almost exclusively people who live here, but really it's a selfish venture. I mean, I think I do
这很奇怪。就像如果你不住在大城市，如果你住在一个小地方，大家就会觉得你一定是在做一个关于那个地方的节目。我搞不懂。但这也就是我把名字里的“佛蒙特”去掉的原因。这可能意味着我的节目几乎只采访住在这里的人，但实际上这是一个自私的举动。我是说，我觉得我做
the show to figure out how to get through my day better. And so every single person that you talk to knows something that if you knew it, you could get through your day better. I mean, I think I believe that, right? So, and I think that that's, you know, not just about for I think somebody in Ohio might find something edifying in the show, you know, even though the person lives in Hardwick, you know, so it's not really about Vermont, but at Varrett, you get you do feel Vermont in it pretty strongly. Well, I feel like I do. And it's one of the things I actually love about it
这个节目是为了弄清楚怎么更好地度过每一天。因此，你与之交谈的每一个人都知道一些事情，如果你也知道的话，你就能更好地度过这一天。我是说，我想我是相信这一点的，对吧？所以，而且我认为，你知道的，不仅仅是为了我，我觉得俄亥俄州的某个人也可能会在这个节目中找到有益的东西，你知道的，尽管这个人住在哈德威克，你知道的，所以它其实不是关于佛蒙特州的，但在瓦雷特，你确实能很强烈地感受到佛蒙特州的氛围。嗯，我觉得我是这样觉得的。而且这也是我实际上非常喜欢它的原因之一
that it's deeply local and I think that it's intimate because of your association with the place and you wanting to talk to people and having access to people that it is rooted in a community. But it absolutely does speak to a wider audience. I mean, it's funny that you bristle at the idea of, it being located in like, not New York and not LA.
它是极其本土化的，而且我认为它是亲切的，因为你与这个地方的联系，你想要与人交谈，并且能够接触到人们，它根植于一个社区。但它绝对能引起更广泛受众的共鸣。我是说，很有意思的是，当别人把它定位为像“不是纽约”和“不是洛杉矶”时，你会有所抗拒。
Maybe that's what I should have called my show. I should have called it not New York and not LA. That would have been a great name. It would tell me a little bit about this association with RumbleStrip and Vermont and like, is this a show that could be made anywhere? Like, what is that association? Like, is it just where you are
也许这就是我该给节目起的名字。我应该把它叫做“不是纽约和不是洛杉矶”。那会是个绝佳的名字。它会告诉我一些关于“Rumble Strip”和佛蒙特州之间这种联系的事情，比如，这是一个可以在任何地方制作的节目吗？比如，这种联系是什么？比如，这只是因为你在那里
and therefore that's where your stories are or something else? I think it's that. I think, I mean, or, I mean, I don't know because I think that part of the reason for the show is this very, very deep love hate relationship with where I live. You know, it's like, I've never been married,
所以你的故事就在那里，还是有别的原因？我觉得就是这样。我觉得，我的意思是，或者说，我不知道，因为我觉得节目的一部分原因在于，我对居住的地方有着非常非常深的爱恨交织的关系。你知道，这就像，我从来没有结过婚，
but I imagine that you hate your spouse on some level. Or it's that, you know, I mean, you see their blind spots, right? And you sort of gently look away and indicate it's sort of over there, my friend, right? But I think that I didn't hear my state on the radio. I didn't get the feeling that the dark parts were ever being heard or the confusing or banal parts of love and hate. But I think I'm also compelled to make stuff. And so if I lived in Topeka, I'd probably do this there in the same, you know, in the same way, although it would be trying to figure out what the hell is Topeka. I mean, I guess that's what I'm trying to do here too. That makes sense.
但我猜你在某种程度上会讨厌你的配偶。或者说，你知道的，你能看到他们的盲点，对吧？然后你就会温柔地移开视线，暗示着，那啥，我的朋友，就在那边，对吧？但我觉得我没有在广播里听到我的州的声音。我从来没有感觉到黑暗的部分被倾听过，或者爱与恨中那些令人困惑或平庸的部分。但我觉得我也有一种创作的冲动。所以如果我住在托皮卡，我大概也会以同样的方式在那里做这个，你知道的，虽然这需要我去弄清楚托皮卡到底是什么鬼。我是说，我想这也是我在这里努力想做的事。这说得通。
But I am definitely of this place. Yeah. But it really is the strength of the show in a lot of ways is that where it is. Are you someone who I have found that I have hard time talking to people in my normal life? And so I created a job that would force me to talk to people. You're an extroverted introvert. Exactly. That's what I am. I'm an extroverted introvert. And I have never, ever had, including this one, I was just going to be honest. I've never done an interview that I didn't really hope was going to get canceled.
但我绝对是属于这个地方的。是的。但从很多方面来看，节目的优势确实在于它的所在地。你是一个……我发现我在现实生活中很难与人交谈，所以我创造了一份迫使我与人交谈的工作。你是个外向的内向者。完全正确。我就是这样。我是一个外向的内向者。而且我从来没有——包括这一次，我只想实话实说——从来没有做过一次采访，是我不打心底里希望它被取消的。
Because I'm so nervous all the time. I mean, if you're knocking on somebody's door and it's a perfect stranger, I'm just praying they're gonna be like, you know, today's not gonna work out. But because it's the scariest thing, it will talk to you're asking a lot of somebody to stick a mic in their face and to have an intimate conversation.
因为我无时无刻不在紧张。我是说，如果你在敲别人的门，而对方是个完完全全的陌生人，我只能祈祷他们会说，你知道的，今天不太合适。但正因为这是最可怕的事情，你要跟人谈话，你要求别人把麦克风怼到脸前，还要进行一次深入的对话，这需要对方付出很多。
And that's very high stakes. And I'm very not an extrovert, you know? But you ask really intimate questions. I mean, you really get into people's lives. How do you overcome that? Well, I think that you just fall in to someone. And that's the, I mean, I guess in the beginning, you just sweat it out until you get everything set up, right?
而且这赌注很高。我非常不外向，你知道吗？但你问的问题真的很深入。我是说，你真的走进了人们的生活。你是怎么克服这一点的？嗯，我觉得你只是坠入了某个人的世界。这就是……我是说，我想一开始，你只是在把一切都设置好之前紧张得直冒汗，对吧？
But then you fall in. I think I reglassed this too, and I really agree with it, which is I don't think I've ever not fallen in love with the person that I'm interviewing, and you maybe you feel that way too. It's just, you just fall in love with them. You know, nine year olds and 13 year olds, and everything in between. So I think that once the light switch goes on,
但随后你就投入进去了。我觉得我对此也有同感，而且我真的很赞同，那就是我觉得我从来没有不爱上我正在采访的人，你可能也会有这种感觉。就是，你就是会爱上他们。你知道的，9岁的孩子和13岁的孩子，以及介于两者之间的所有人。所以我觉得一旦灯光开关打开，
I think that when you get to a place in an interview where you've asked a question that you're both kind of stumped by. I feel like you know you're in that third place together, that like its own country. And I don't think there's anything more exciting than that. I couldn't agree more. It's the greatest. It is. It is. And I worry sometimes, I have been worrying lately about feeling as though I'm taking. I don't ever want to feel that I've left an inner. I want somebody to feel more than they felt before.
我觉得当你在采访中达到了这样一个地步：你问了一个让你们俩都有些摸不着头脑的问题。我觉得你知道你们一起进入了那种第三空间，就像是一个属于它自己的国度。我觉得没有什么比这更令人兴奋的了。我不能同意更多了。这是最棒的。确实是。确实是。而且有时我会有所担忧，我最近一直在担心，觉得自己像是在索取。我永远不想让人觉得我进行了一次采访后留下了……我希望对方感觉比以前感受到的更多。
Oh, totally. Yeah. You want them to leave like, like, they, oh, they got the job. You wanted them to feel like I did it. Exactly. Right. Or that they, that they would have said, oh, my God, I never knew I thought that. But then there are sometimes I feel like I did it. Exactly. Right. Or that they said, oh my god, I never knew I thought that. But then there are sometimes I feel like I've taken and that's very upsetting.
哦，完全是这样。是的。你希望他们离开时感觉……就像他们被录取了一样。你希望他们觉得“我做到了”。完全正确。对吧？或者他们会说，“哦，天哪，我从没想过我会有这种想法”。但有时我觉得我是在索取，这真的很让人心烦。
Or I mean, I think I don't feel that way often. I guess I worry sometimes that I could slip there. Yeah, I get that. So your subjects are mainly around your geographic area and Vermont. Where do you picture your listeners as being from? Like how much do you explain about where you are based off your image of who your audience is? That's hard because I know that there are Vermont listeners
或者说，我觉得我并不经常有这种感觉。我想我有时会担心自己会滑向那一边。是的，我懂。所以你的采访对象主要围绕你的地理区域和佛蒙特州。你想象你的听众来自哪里？比如，你会在多大程度上根据你对听众形象的想象来解释你所在的所在地？这很难，因为我知道有些佛蒙特州的听众
who already know the backstory of it. Well, actually though, you know, I mean, Burlington, Vermont is another country from where I live in Vermont. I mean, entirely. I mean, it's their worlds, their worlds away. So they need, they need some context also. But I feel like it's, you can, it's so gestural. If you can just get, I mean, even if you use the person's first and last name, like John Smith told me, like you get at a sense of what the place is very gesturally without having to say, in this area, people know one another, you know, and so and so knows his name, whatever,
他们已经知道背后的故事了。不过话说回来，你知道的，佛蒙特州的伯灵顿跟我所住的佛蒙特州简直是另一个世界。我是说，完全是。我是说，它们是天壤之别。所以他们也需要一些背景信息。但我觉得你可以……这太具暗示性了。如果你能做到……我是说，哪怕你用了被采访者的全名，比如“约翰·史密斯告诉我”，你也能非常含蓄地感受到这个地方是什么样的，而不必非得说“在这个地区，人们互相认识，你知道的，某某知道他的名字，诸如此类”，
you know, I feel like I've gotten better or not, I better not worrying about how much I need to explain about this place. And that always less is more. I mean, I write these long intros that turn into four sentences, which takes an entire day and sometimes too. Yeah. Yeah. We sit in a room and edit basically everything that comes out on the show.
你知道的，我觉得我在这方面做得越来越好了，或者说不用再去担心我需要对这个地方解释多少了。而且往往少即是多。我是说，我写了这些长长的引言，最后精简成了四句话，这有时候甚至需要花上一整天的时间。对。对。我们坐在一个房间里，基本上对节目中播出的所有内容进行剪辑。
There's like at least seven or eight of us in a room going through a line-by-line and we call it nine NPI rights of sentence. And usually the result of it is just cutting the sentence, almost like a good half the time. You know, we'll like hone in and hone in and hone in. Like, wait, wait, wait, what if we just not say this? Absolutely. Yeah, there's a profound relief like nobody cares. Nobody needs to know that part. You know, eight people, I'm trying to even imagine what that's like. You know, it's really, you know, like I started my show as a single person alone in room. It got more and more and more. And one of the things it does is it sort of gives it a different kind of life where I can inhabit the genius
房间里至少有七八个人，逐行逐句地审阅，我们称之为“99PI的句子权利”。通常结果就是删掉这个句子，几乎有一半的时间都是如此。你知道的，我们会不断地精炼、精炼、再精炼。比如，等一下，等一下，等一下，如果我们不说这句话会怎么样？绝对是。是的，有一种深深的解脱感，因为根本没人会在意。没人需要知道那一部分。你知道，八个人，我甚至在努力想象那是什么感觉。你知道的，这真的很……就像我刚开始做节目时，是一个人在房间里孤军奋战。后来人越来越多、越来越多。它带来的效果之一就是，它赋予了节目一种不同的人生，我可以沉浸在别人的天才之中
of others, you know, or just like struggle through it all alone. And it's a different skill, but it's super fun. And it does kind of, it changes it a little bit. Like if I were to listen back to my orderly awful shows, I'm much more likely to make a broad generalization joke because it's just a single point of view and it doesn't get like run through a group of people who go, that's not working for me. We're not liking the jokes so much.
你知道的，或者只是独自苦苦挣扎。这是另一种技能，但超级有趣。它确实在某种程度上改变了节目。如果我回听自己那些井井有条却又糟糕透顶的节目，我更有可能会开一个宏大的泛泛而谈的玩笑，因为这只是单一的视角，而且没有经过一群人的审视，不会有人说：“这对我不管用。我们其实不太喜欢这些笑话。”
So there's a change in it, but the robustness of the collective genius of all the people I work with, where getting, they're just better at so many other things than I am, makes it so much better. And so yeah, it changes, but you learn how to sort of roll with it in different ways. But I like each, I've liked each phase in different ways. Well, and there's a way in which there's a way in which the, you know, and this is a part of not having eight people in the room, there's a being alone, you know, there is a way in which I, you know, I do worry.
所以节目确实发生了变化，但我合作的所有人的集体智慧的强大力量——他们在很多其他事情上都比我做得更好——让节目变得好得多。所以，是的，节目变了，但你学会了如何以不同的方式去适应它。不过我喜欢每一个阶段，喜欢的方式各不相同。嗯，而且在某种程度上，在某种程度上……你知道的，这也是房间里没有八个人的原因之一，那就是独自一人，你知道的，在某种程度上，我，你知道的，确实会担心。
I always have to ask myself, am I romanticizing this place? You know, am I slipping into tropes? Will anyone tell me when I am? Will someone make a bird sound that says, it's time to get off the bus, you know, you're done. I mean, like this farmer I interviewed recently, Forest Foster, he's like, he's from another century, right? And there is, I mean, there is easy to other if I him, right? But what I do trust is I have much less interest
我总是不得不问自己：我是不是在把这个地方浪漫化？你知道的，我是不是陷入了陈词滥调？当我有这种倾向时，会有人告诉我吗？会有人发出像小鸟叫一样的声音说：“是时候下车了，你知道的，你结束了”？我是说，就像我最近采访的一位农民福雷斯特·福斯特，他就像是另一个世纪的人，对吧？而且，我是说，把他“他者化”是很轻而易举的，对吧？但我真正信任的是，我对
in talking about the past than I do about talking about, like, how do you get through today? Like, what do you, you know, how do you think about this? Like what's going on is really the operating question. And that brings it back to, I think that that steers me away from romanticizing somehow. And again, selfishness, always selfishness. Like what do you know that I want for myself, that I want to have? So that's not making something pretty for other people. It's like, what do I get from knowing you? What have I learned here? And hopefully that is what I focus in or focus on when I make a show. I just, you know, the idea is to invite people into the front seat of other people's lives.
谈论过去的兴趣，远小于谈论“你今天是怎么度过的？”。比如，你对此怎么看？眼下正在发生什么才是真正核心的问题。这让我觉得，这在某种程度上把我从浪漫化中拉了回来。再说一次，还是自私，永远是自私。比如，你知道什么是我为自己想要的，是我想要得到的？所以这不是为别人做一些漂亮的东西。而是，我从了解你这里得到了什么？我在这里学到了什么？希望这就是我制作节目时所关注或聚焦的重点。我只是，你知道的，我们的想法就是邀请听众进入别人生活的副驾驶座。
And if you find a thread, even if you really dislike the person, if you find a thread of logic to how they've come to where they are, then you can't dissociate from them somehow. You find yourself in them, even in the people that you most dislike. And I guess that seems like a useful thing to be doing right now. You know, that's the goal. That's a good goal. Well, thank you so much for sharing the story and your podcast with us, Erica. Thank you. You can find RumbleStrip wherever you get your podcasts.
如果你能找到一条线索，即使你非常不喜欢这个人，如果你能从他们如何走到今天这一步的过程中找到逻辑的线索，那么你就无法以某种方式与他们割裂开来。你会从他们身上找到自己的影子，哪怕是在你最讨厌的人身上。我想这似乎是一件当下很有价值的事情。你知道的，这就是目标。这是一个很好的目标。好了，非常感谢埃里卡跟我们分享这个故事和你的节目。谢谢。你可以在任何能听到播客的地方找到 Rumble Strip。
And if you'd like a suggestion of where to start, I recommend listening to the episode called Finn and the Bell. It's about a young man named Finn who killed himself in 2020. But the story isn't about suicide. It's about who he was as a person and how the small community around him staggered forward after such a tragedy. It didn't quite fit the purview of 99PI for us to feature it here, but I think it's probably in contention for the best audio documentary I've ever heard.
如果你想要一个从哪里开始听的建议，我建议你听一听那集叫《芬恩与钟》的节目。讲的是一个叫芬恩的年轻人，他在2020年自杀了。但这个故事不是关于自 suic（自杀）的。它是关于他作为一个怎样的人，以及他周围的小社区在经历这样一场悲剧后是如何艰难前行的。它不太符合我们99PI在这里展示的范畴，但我认为它可能是我听过的最好的音频纪录片之一。
It can be a tough listen, especially if you have teenage kids. I actually avoided it for a while, even though it was recommended to me by everyone who works on this show. But once it started playing, I realized that I was in really good hands and it is so rewarding. That episode again is called Finn and the Bell from Rumble Strap.
听这集可能会有点难受，特别是如果你有十几岁的孩子的话。其实我有一段时间一直躲着不听，尽管做这档节目的每个人都向我推荐了它。但一旦播放起来，我意识到我是在极好的照顾下聆听的，而且它收获匪浅。那集的名称再次是——来自 Rumble Strip 的《芬恩与钟》。
You should listen. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmet Fitzgerald, mixed in tech production by Martín González. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barupé, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Jason Dalyone, Sophia Klassker, Swanriao, and me Roman Mars. We are part of this Stitcher and Serious
你们应该去听听。本周的《99%无形》由埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德制作，技术制作和混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成。德兰妮·霍尔是执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员有：薇薇安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴吕佩、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什马冬、杰森·达利奥恩、索菲亚·克拉斯克、斯旺里奥，以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius
XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show
XM 播客家族的一员，总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区上城。你可以找到这个节目
and join discussions about the show on Facebook you can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org were on Instagram Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. I'm sorry. www.cabriss.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并在 Facebook 上加入关于节目的讨论，你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，也可以在 99PI org 上找到这个节目，我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 99PI dot org 上找到我喜欢其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 过去的每一集节目。我很抱歉。www.cabriss.com 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。